[Music]
hey everybody
what's up we're streaming on a new
computer for the first so please please
tell me if the uh
sound sounds okay because i had to
i had to do all the new like [ __ ] on
here and i'm just like i can't remember
all the settings so i don't know if i
[ __ ] them up or not the image seems to
be
the same okay that's good that's good
so it's not because what we're seeing
what we're seeing on our monitor here is
like
sound is off the sound's off as an off
off like you can't hear anything
[ __ ] what yeah there's no sound no it's
muffled
sounds muffled maybe this
looks good [ __ ] man
okay i got this dog hanging
the sound dog the sound yeah yeah
okay that's fine that's fine
i don't know why it would be
like that
maybe i can turn it down
no not that much hold on
yeah sound test
oh he said okay so maybe it was just up
too high
might have been up too high or something
how about this how about that is that
fine
or maybe it was too far away okay maybe
it was yeah i think maybe it was just
too far away
we should just leave well it would be
like an ed wood movie
well it's better than being here so yeah
yeah that was like better yeah while i
was on vacation he got the
arm the boom arm and like hooked it all
up and all that other kind of stuff
yeah there's i still wish it was in a
slightly different position but there's
nothing to do about it
well what are you gonna do like i said
it's better than being here and like in
front of everyone's chest and stuff yeah
i kind of would like it right here
and out of the out of the view
anyway today's show looks like people
showed up at least we got some in there
uh today's show
is about bread
bread in western civilization
is like nectar of the gods
the icker of life bread
and bread was just flour water and a few
little components maybe some eggs and
some butter
you can make bread um
you had whole most of the western
civilization the poor people just
surviving on bread
and beer yeah because that's basically
the same thing beer is drinkable bread
in many ways
and today you know i mean when you want
bread you use bread and sandwiches and
you can you know
use it in certain desserts you know call
it cake
people tend to buy it so today's show
is going to be a very kind of like brief
outline um to encourage
newbies who've never made bread to
to make bread it's it's very cheap to
make
it's easy to make and it's and it can be
made
fast as long as you have as you have the
ingredients
and you've planned ahead it's not like
well damn i'm going to make a sandwich
let me go make the bread it's not like
that
sandwich like three hours yeah
the bread should have been made already
so tammy said love your shirt jenny
thank you
yeah i got this ripley's believe it or
not museum in santa cruz yeah
i got a bunch of shirts yeah yeah you
filling that shirt out too
look at that
oh man oh my goodness yeah last night we
went out to the club so i'm kind of like
[ __ ] up still yeah it's kind of slow
it was decent night though
yeah it was fun yeah got chicken and
waffles at the end of the night that was
nice
yeah they had these uh three
bikini fitness [ __ ] competition girls
in there
came in those they were just [ __ ]
shredded they were probably in their 40s
or 50s
jenny was there dancing i was there
dancing and over her shoulder there both
three of them are back there [ __ ]
staring at me judging me
and [ __ ] i had to sit there and be
judged by these [ __ ]
oh shredded as bikini girls look
you didn't know you remember that movie
underwater yeah when they were walking
underwater in the damn cthulhu monster
came out and the little monsters popped
out and looked at him
yeah that's what it felt like six damn
eyeballs looking at me
going like what's his bite you know what
you know why the hell
you know why the hell isn't he 50 15
body fat
you know like that you know looking up
and down i don't know he might be
something in a couple years but no
you know that [ __ ] you you don't know
they were thinking i don't know it was
something like that
i mean you don't know they were looking
fantastic they were looking at me like
yeah
it's kind of like a baby bat you know
how like we look at a baby bed or
something like a new goth they're like
who's that guy which is
what gym does he go to yeah you know
they were talking to each other looking
at me like who's that [ __ ] you
know
anyway it's kind of like we would look
why are they wearing those shoes yeah
it's like what's those cargo shorts
yeah why are they wearing the yeah
that's that what why are you in a
nightclub wearing that
yeah you look ridiculous you look
ridiculous at a nightclub with those
flip-flops
we saw a lot of that [ __ ] anyway uh yeah
i
somebody had said about the audio
clipping it's it was because it wasn't
this it was the settings
because uh it turned the microphone all
the way up
like in the settings on here so i just
fixed it yeah so they said it's fixed
all right sounds a lot better just a
little low well now i'm going to turn it
up on here
okay because like i said i i wasn't sure
this is the first time that we're
streaming with this new one that is
very very thoughtfully uh given to us by
no need for me to yeah send it to us and
it's
awesome so far it seems to be so i got
it set up all day yesterday and i was
like i did some recording
like just for yeah purposes uh
you know but this is the first time
we're streaming with it so okay sounds
good now so it's perfect okay okay
okay jenny's gonna uh retire the other
computer being an auxiliary
yeah it's always nice to be a business
computer yeah
i mean and i i gotta get a new battery
for my mac too that's my graphic design
one so
yeah that's gonna be on the way yeah and
uh
what do you want to do with this this uh
pc
this tower do you want to want to update
that or is it good enough the way it's
going
that one's good enough i was pretty much
all i use that one for is uh
you know browsing the internet like for
research and a little bit of video
editing okay that's about all right
so keep me advised if that starts
falling behind we'll do something about
that one too because that one was
donated also that was a second hand
yeah old one it seems to be working
though yeah
okay so get back to brad
um the easiest quickest bread that you
can make would be shortbread
and that's a good bread that you would
use like for survival
you know what i mean some survival bread
if you don't put any sugar in it it's
shortbread
if you put sugar in it it's short cake
you know like if you're gonna make
strawberry shortcake or basically this
recipe is
basically what you use uh it's basically
how to make your own bisquick
that's all it is and with that you can
modify it
you can look at all the recipes on there
you can take that and actually water it
down and turn it into pancake mix too
there's all different kinds of things
that you can do
and it's nothing but just all-purpose
flour
all right unbleached all-purpose flour
some kind of shortening like crisco i
like this butter flavored crisco that
you can get now it's really nice
it's just yellow i like that as well
yeah it's kind of like butter
but a lot less expensive requires no
refrigeration
you can keep it in your house open
forever and it won't spoil
so if you're ever in a hurricane and you
lose power you can still
make bread with this it won't go bad
like
if you lose power the air conditioning
goes down and all your butter starts to
melt
okay so your butter is going to go
[ __ ] bad probably
well it won't go bad it'll just turn
into [ __ ] slime
a better puddle and butter puddle but
crisco
or shortening it doesn't really care
what temperature it is you can still use
it
um and it doesn't spoil or anything it's
vegetable product you know so
it's safe so it's just
flour shortening a little bit of
of uh uh they call it
stuff make it rise uh yeast and
a little bit of uh water or milk
and i've used um
uh i've made my own milk out of the
powdered milk you know powdered milk
but you actually it doesn't even have to
be milk really in in a real
you know if you're in a real pinch do
you have the the recipe ahead
what it is i have a couple of ones i
have like a just a regular
uh white bread recipe which is one for
the shortbread
well it's see when you say shortbread
people think you mean like shortbread
like the cookie you know what i mean
yeah that's like a different thing
okay because you got like you know you
got like your regular bread which is
with yeast and then you have your quick
bread
which is doesn't have yeast uh and quick
bread is [ __ ] like you know zucchini
bread banana bread right all that kind
of stuff you know waffles that kind of
stuff
um but your regular white bread is just
uh
bread flour or all-purpose flour you can
use that too a little bit of sugar
a little bit of salt a little bit of
shortening yeast
water and butter or or or
veggie or or um what do you call it or
crisco
you can use that in exchange with butter
yeah but the the um
what i was talking about i call it
some people would call it shortcake
yeah okay it makes a little muffin
type thing and that that's what you
would use for like strawberry shortcake
the difference is is that strawberry the
short cake
and the short bread that's what we used
to call it
the difference was whether or not it had
sugar or not in it
yeah that's all it was if you put sugar
in it it was a little bit sweeter
you know it was more cake-like yeah and
it was it there there's really nothing
to it
if you've never made any of this bread
try it all you need is a big bowl
measuring cups and like a nice a decent
rubber spatula when it comes to spatulas
i like to use
um what you call an egg flipper that's
what they would call it in the civilian
world
it's like a it's like a spatula
but it's shaped more like a knife it's a
lot longer and it's
and it's got kind of like an angle to it
it's like a blade and it allows you to
flip over omelets a lot better but the
thing is is that that's really good at
mixing
batter you can scrape along the inside
of the bowl and get a lot of it
you know what i mean in a bigger swipe
when you're making this
short breads and bread as it starts as
you're mixing it and it starts to pull
away from the bowl
you're going to probably want to put
vegetable oil in there to help it pull
away from the bowl
and isolate itself from the bowl so it
ends up being a
a ball of of dough
that is um kind of like suspended off of
your bowl
in a slight um you know suspended
slightly with on with the
on a glaze of oil yeah which allows you
to get some of it out
it also allows you to tear pieces of it
off but there's a bunch of video
tutorials
and everything you need online to help
you make
breads all right and uh
knowing how to make bread is is a very
valuable skill
especially in a pinch i saw this um
somebody pointed this out on one of
these uh uh
things that i listened to they're
talking about
millennials and the newer generations
well over there in russia
they were talking to putin and one of
these little tough ass [ __ ]
russian boys just asked him a question
he says how do we become
stronger men more manly that's what the
[ __ ] kid he gives about 18
19 ass putin that and putin says learn
how to cook
and they laughed and he goes no no no no
no
this is good advice every man should
learn how to cook
because that is an essential survival
skill no matter where you are you just
what do you do
depend on your mom to cook for you you
know
you better you know every man should
learn how to cook well everybody should
at least know the
you know rudimentary yeah you know you
don't have to be like a chef or anything
but everybody should at least know how
to make a few things
exactly you should know how to how to
feed yourself and uh
and when when i heard that pootie gave
that little pooty poo gave that invite
that advice i was like yep that's right
because
evidently kind of like in in in the
russian manosphere
uh cooking is kind of like a feminine
thing and they're they neglect
it you know in their mind i kind of feel
like that's
to a certain extent that was not so much
nowadays because that you know
everybody's in
foodies nowadays so it's not seen as
like so feminine anymore but i feel like
particularly in the 50s and stuff like
that in the us
right that was like that was that was
woman [ __ ] but then the dumb thing was
like
chefs like high caliber chefs were
almost all men
yeah and you didn't say you know like i
said not nowadays but back then and all
the famous ones were men
yeah and somehow that wasn't the working
class
the women didn't work jobs outside the
home they worked inside the home it was
a full-time job yeah
taking care of kids cleaning things
growing food making food
so kitchen duty fell on the the working
class
women in in that era
but rich people had their meals cooked
for them
and you know what i mean it was in the
top
chefs were these french chefs and they
were running
a french system that i talked about in
another yeah
we did about sauces yeah right it was um
the french conda and it was it was
really only two or three guys and it was
started in the
mid 1800s they tried
to make a system for cooking starting
off with sauces
where sauces came from they wanted to
approach
they wanted to approach cooking in an
organized fashion like it was science
or alchemy it actually was a lot like
alchemy
which is actually kind of a good analog
i mean you know what i mean yes there's
science involved yes there's chemistry
involved obviously
particularly when you're talking about
bread and baking yeah but
there is there is kind of like finesse
and art to it
yeah because assembling a dish out of a
bunch of components
is not really so much about perfect
measurements because
the components are have slight
variations all the time
the measurement so the things are kind
in other words
you can assemble a dish exactly exactly
by the recipe and it not really come out
that well
because the salt might be off or the
salt
salt sugar ratio might be wrong it has
to be finished off by
taste and taste is the subjective thing
yeah so you're starting to deal with
artwork with art
it's it's which is art and it's kind of
like
alchemy like put some heat on it yeah
that'll be good
taste it yeah it's add a little bit more
of that yeah
okay it tastes right now you know that
so
you can't really codify that yeah
because so much of it is like subjective
yeah it's very and the thing about well
i mean it's a little less so i guess
with baking because baking is a lot more
precise
uh you have to be a lot more precise
particularly when you're baking bread
and stuff like that where
you know it's not quick bread if it's
yeast because
yeast which a lot of people found out i
feel like there was kind of like a mini
trend
during like the beginning of the
pandemic where everybody decided
suddenly
we're gonna make sourdough bread at home
and everybody's trying to do sourdough
starters
and they were talking about like how
[ __ ] difficult it was because the
yeast kept dying and all this other kind
of [ __ ]
uh because i think sourdough i i
i've made sourdough in a bread machine
but i'm not a big fan of sourdough so i
didn't make it that often
but sourdough is kind of is at least as
far
as i could determine like the most
difficult one or the most finicky one
to make at home obviously if you're
gonna start making bread at home it's
probably easier to start with quick
breads because you don't have to [ __ ]
with yeast then
yeah you know what i mean so because you
know banana bread zucchini bread that
kind it's like pumpkin bread all that
kind of stuff is like really easy
because you don't have to worry about
proofing the yeast and making sure you
have the water warm enough and like
you're
you know when the when the uh dough
proofs like the dough rises you have to
have like the kitchen has to be warm
enough and all this other kind of stuff
so there's like all these little factors
that
you know that have to go into it my
advice about bread
all right is you want to source these
components
in bulk if you go to your local grocery
store and you get the little
five pound bags uh you're not really
getting a good deal when it comes to how
much that loaf of bread is gonna cost
you after that
and so it's better than buying it but
it's still not that
economical um now i do it for when i buy
bread flour
because i can only get five pound bread
bread bread flour and five pound bags
that's what i use to make
pizza dough with uh i used to be able to
get it in 20 pound bags but it's gone
now i don't know where
you know like every now and then sams
will have bread flour and big bags but
for sometimes they don't have it it just
depends on whatever
yeah i asked them to order it and they
go yeah we can't get it anymore
so but you can get all-purpose and ge or
general all-purpose flour you can get
that in 20-pound bags
so what you want to do is you want to
get you want to get 20-pound bags
and you say well i don't want a 20 open
20 pound bag
sitting around in my pantry yeah i agree
with you you don't want a 20 pound open
bag so what you do is
is you get a large plastic container
and what i'm actually using to hold
bread flour in
is what used to be a giant um
a big giant square plastic bucket with a
top on it
that was originally cat food little
kitty chow
stuff um it still even has a
like a laser imprinted logo of little
kitty child stuff
but it's that is a bucket that you would
pay about 15 20
for if you bought it yeah they want to
charge you 20 bucks for that bucket if
you bought it as a blank
storage bucket no no no source that [ __ ]
from something else
like kitty chow or a big old thing that
[ __ ] had dry dog food
kitty litter kitty litter yeah because
they sell them in those big
yeah i like that i use the kitty chow
ones i think it's a little more
appetizing and less
you know less unappetizing i mean yeah
you wash it but you watch yeah wash the
[ __ ] out of it and watch
send it through the damn automatic
washing machine too you know it'll be
fine it's totally
sanitized and use that as bread storage
or excuse me flour storage if you start
dealing with hundreds of pounds or 50
pounds
all we used to use in the restaurant is
a damn
plastic garbage can that's all it was a
plastic garbage can with a snap-on lid
that could seal yeah and we'd have 100
pounds of flour sitting in that thing
but we were making fast quantities but
there are some people that want to
stockpile that
much flour you know and i trust it in
that plastic container
over that paper container that they come
in because uh
bugs can't eat through that plastic yeah
though you threw that paper bag yeah it
comes in
or mousey's or mouse'll eat it put it in
a brand new
plastic garbage can put the top on it
and then
seal it shut with duct tape and it would
stay like that for years
it'd be fine all right now
same thing with yeast you're going to
see yeast in these little bitty shake
packets man throw that [ __ ] away all
right that's
forget that no i like the gesture
[Laughter]
go down to sam's and get the big old
[ __ ] industrial cakes of yeast and
it'll be two cakes of yeast there
each one of them is like the size of
five [ __ ] packs of cigarettes
all right and they're usually stuck
together and they're in they're in foil
wrappers and they're stuck together with
shrink wrap
open that [ __ ] up use it and then take
the rest of it and pour it into a
glass jar or a plastic jar and put it in
a door or your refrigerator
so just keep your yeast in the
refrigerator you know i'm keeping that
little plastic bag
everything's storage jenny i'll tell you
if i find a pretty glass bottle
i'm keeping that or a jar or a jar
anything that had like it could have
like you know sun-dried tomatoes in
there or artichoke or artichoke hearts
or whatever
it might have done with them it might
have had uh like the the really nice
really nice glass jar that had spices in
it
yeah it might have had a cork in the top
of it might have a screw-on cap
i'll clean that off if it had any labels
pull those labels off
wipe it all down with lighter fluid to
get all the sticky glue off of it
send it through the washing machine come
back and have a brand new square pretty
bottle
and i'll put red chili flakes down in
there and then pour a bunch of olive oil
in there and shake it and let it cure
and make you know
hot olive oil with it there's all kinds
of stuff you can do with it
or if you have if you want to change the
packaging
you like you get a big old thing of
spices and you're going like i don't
want it in glass
in plastic packaging i'm going to change
it to glass that way i have
i got custom [ __ ] custom containers
[Laughter]
i'm just weird like that i guess you
know well no it's not really i mean
because when
things come in a glass container
especially if it's like a big one yeah
i mean why wouldn't you use why would
you just throw that away it's really
useful
that's a yeah and like that glass
jar especially if it's a pretty shape
if you were to just buy that jar it
would have cost you a lot of money
they want your cards you like three or
four bucks they're essentially giving
you a job they're giving you a free jar
and i have all my jars and all my spices
and stuff and you
you could put them up on your counter
for display and they're pretty
yeah you know you know it's not these
plastic [ __ ]
containers with the you know pictures of
people looking at you and [ __ ]
garish colors and [ __ ] you know nah man
classic [ __ ]
so uh classy [ __ ] classy [ __ ] so
that was another secret that i'm getting
to at the bread storage
buy big learn how to store it
this [ __ ] goes back to ancient egypt man
where they're storing the wheat and
trying to protect
the first born from the [ __ ] down in
the land of goshen
you know what i mean when evil angels
were coming across killing their
firstborn
you know i remember when that happened
when that should happen they had to
protect
[ __ ] grain silos fr
plagues of frogs plagues of [ __ ]
flies plagues of simps they just simply
simpinate easy okay yeah
imagine that imagine if you got attacked
by a plague of sims
make a lot of money though i i guess
make a lot of money
yeah what does that have to do with
bread though i don't know
it just went down that way has nothing
to do with bread this is just the
entertaining story
just taking us back to the old testament
it's when they just made bread what else
recipes what else kind of bread do we
have in there lined up well like i said
we had you wanted to talk about
uh multigrain yeah
and i had kind of a i have found this
little thing i was actually i was
watching a video i can't remember what
the dude's name was but he was making
he had like a uh he had a recipe where
you didn't have to knead it and it
actually came out really good like
you just mixed around yeah yeah yeah uh
he had one like that and he had uh
one making focaccia okay yeah which was
really cool
but you could see how that one seemed a
little bit more difficult because the
dough was kind of like
it kept like bouncing back yeah and he's
like you have to keep kind of like
pushing it down
you have to kind of squish it and like
let it because you want it to go to the
edges of the
pan that you're cooking it in so it's
like big and square and [ __ ]
but uh yeah but i found this uh thing
too that was like talking about like
troubleshooting tips and [ __ ] like that
because a lot of
i feel like a lot of stuff there is a
lot of stuff that can go wrong
especially if you're making like a yeast
one
yeah right i mean because you put in and
we talked about this a little bit when
we
were doing the pizza show because you
were talking about making the
the dough i don't think you've ever had
the yeast like [ __ ] up though
no because there's something you have
most people have people have to
understand that there's something called
shocking bread
you can shock a dough and [ __ ] it up
that's where you have
let's say you have uh yeast uh
making a culture inside the sugar water
all right and it's growing you can smell
it
oh man that's beautiful and then it
comes time to start
adding water to that
all right and then the flour to that
okay
if you add the flour too quickly
and just start mixing like you put all
of it in there and just mix it
all right it'll shock the flour it'll
it'll it'll taste terrible
you can't do it it won't rise right
it'll taste it'll be like cardboard
all right you have to add the
flour in there slowly and mix it in
there slowly you can't shock it
that's the same that's probably the same
thing you're talking about with with
with bread
this isn't i know not to shock flour
you know it's even not to shock your
dough yeah you know
i just you're mixing it in there slowly
if you
don't mix it in there slowly it's just
gonna [ __ ] up it's got to go in there
and um the tutorials or the directions
on any of your
recipes for any kind of bread you want
to make follow them they're telling you
to do [ __ ]
on purpose they're trying to get you to
avoiding shocking the dough
yeah because you can't i mean dough is i
mean making bread is something you can't
really be impatient with
no you really got to take your time it
is fast though once you get it
once you understand it doesn't take a
long time
you it's just you can't rush it you have
to do the proper step
yeah yeah i mean you have to do like i
said
you have to add the flour to the yeast
like really really slowly or it's going
to [ __ ] it up
then when you you have to let it rise
for you know a couple of hours then you
have to come back in and you have to
knead it to get all the gluten going
yeah then you have to let it rise again
and then so you really it's you know but
i think a lot of people like
doing it for that very reason because
it's almost kind of it's almost kind of
like relaxing
you know what i'm saying yeah kinda and
then and then at the end of it you have
like delicious [ __ ] bread
one thing that the guy said and i had
actually never heard anybody say this
but he's like i hate to tell you this
but
your bread is going to be best after you
take it out of the oven i know you're
going to want to stick it in your face
like immediately because it's warm and
everything but he's like it's actually
much better
if you leave it to cool completely for
like an hour before you eat it because
like the texture is correct
but i'm like see i don't think i could
wait that long because normally but when
i made bread i just as soon as i pulled
it out i was just like yeah
they want the fluffy bread yeah i want
fluffy warm bread a lot of people may
we're
gonna make a big batch of bread so you
can do what you want you can eat one of
it
some of it as soon as it comes out and
let the rest of it
chill here's another thing is that um
depending on what kind of dough you've
made some doughs can be frozen
and then thawed out and when they're
thawed back out you can make
you can make bread directly from you
know from from a thawed out dough
um so when you make like when i make
pizza dough
it'd be the same for bread though make
enough of it
make quite a bit of it if you're going
to make it make a lot of it
you know and you can use some of it now
and then you you know
then store some of it just in the
refrigerator in a ziploc bag but you
kind of leave it leave it open so it can
breathe a little bit
you might want to knead it every you
know day or so that it's in the
refrigerator and over the pack over the
next like two three four days
pull pieces of it off of it make bread
or make make a small pizza dough
make a small pizza something like that
well you can um
do that with some of the dough and then
some of the other dough you could uh
make it put it in little round balls
wrap it in plastic
and put it in the freezer and freeze it
so
a couple months later if you want a
little small uh
loaf of bread just pull one of those
balls out
set it on the counter and let it thaw
all day and then go out there and knead
it
it'll be it'll come back to life and
then
cook it cook it as a loaf of bread you
can do it
and once bread is cooked it also freezes
really well yeah because a lot of times
if we just buy bread we
we buy a lot of it like it sands and
then we just freeze a bunch that'll last
like a couple months in there
the secret to the secret to freezing
cooked bread
is the thawing process when the bread
comes out of the fridge
freezer you're going to see ice crystals
on it you want to take it out of the
wrapper and get it get
get all those ice crystals off of it
wipe it down
with a clean rag
because if you leave it in a plastic
wrapper that
the ice crystals will melt and it'll end
up sitting in water
and when it sits in water it'll start to
mold
yeah so you want to dry off the outside
of it get those ice crystals off
let it thaw outside it once once the uh
once the loaf is thawed take a clean
towel
and because we use uh kitchen towels
real kitchen towels not paper towels a
real towel you can buy them at
sam's big packet of them for a couple
dollars and you can wash them in the
washing machine
bleach them and everything just like at
a restaurant you'll save money over
paper towels just by using regular
towels so when the thing fl
thaws out thawed out on a towel and then
pat it dry
and then put it in plastic and then put
it in the refrigerator
yeah that's how you do it yeah so that's
i was going to ask too somebody uh danny
rowland ghostface said i say dunkin
donuts should recycle their old donuts
into bread pudding
instead of trashing them i kind of wish
most
every every restaurant even if it's fast
food
they should totally be like [ __ ]
recycling that food we just like waste
so much [ __ ] food in this country the
way those corporations
look at it they didn't hardly spend any
money
on that stuff those are that's like
table scraps they just throw it away
i know it's sad uh to give it away
sometimes they will give it away
um but they're kind of afraid that it's
a liability
but you're right any any kind of old
bread or or or doughnuts or
tons of stuff you can do with that you
can turn that into bread pudding yeah
um you would think that they would sell
it but
there's a lot of waste in the food in
the food industry there's just a lot i
mean we did have
i remember and i'm sure it's there's
some around here too but i remember near
where we grew up in daytona there's a
there was a store and all they sold
was you know bread and cakes and stuff
like that
from the grocery stores that were a
couple of days old
yeah you know what i mean like once the
everything came out of the bakery and
that it was the end of the day like
somebody would come by in the truck and
drop them off
and you could buy them for like a buck
or something like that and honestly it's
like most of the time it's
it's totally still fine and most of the
time if i'm gonna eat beet and bread i'm
gonna toast it anyways
so it doesn't matter if it's a little
bit stale as long as it doesn't have
[ __ ]
mold on it i'll eat it i don't care but
um
i was gonna say i was gonna ask you how
you felt about bread machines
because i used to have a bread machine
and
i it made like pretty [ __ ] decent
bread and you could make you could well
you could make pizza dough in it you
could make
all different kinds of [ __ ] i've never
i've never
you talked about a a mixer no a bread
machine
i've never seen i've never had one never
even dealt with one really no everything
by hand
everything just in regular ovens
basically they're they're about yay big
you can get bigger ones if you want i
think the one i had was maybe like 100
bucks
i think you can get them now for maybe
60 70 for like a basic one
uh it's got like a little thing in it
all you do you put in all the
ingredients
into the pan you close it you set
whatever kind of bread you want how dark
do you want the crust yada yada
it does everything it needs it it lets
it rise and it bakes it
okay and then it takes depends on the
kind of bread but i think it took
i think just for regular basic bread i
want to say like it took
three or four hours like all together
but like i said it was kneading it and
then letting it rise and needing it lift
but it the machine does everything
and then at the end you have like a
little so they usually like a little two
pound
machine another thing that i made uh one
time
is i made some unleavened flatbreads
based on naan
yeah indian flatbread that [ __ ] was easy
i forgot what it was
cause i think naan and pita does
actually have yeast in it but you can
make like different kinds that don't
have that
that don't have yeast in it i used it
was something like uh
butter which i think they use ghee
um melted butter i think it was flour
and um milk
i think it was milk yeah might have been
yogurt
i think it was a mix i think what it was
is i i um
took milk and then uh broke down a
little bit of sour cream in it
and made that into a yogurt yeah i think
that's what yeah and then i made a dough
and then i took a pizza stone
and i put it on the gas grill and
turned it all the way up real high
covered it and got that stone
real hot and then turned the flames down
a little bit
and threw those pieces of non on there
and remember that made sep i made a
sandwich with that
yeah [ __ ] was good was it it was i did
it and i just wanted to see what the
bare minimum
it took to make bread yeah
and you can make bread with damn near
nothing
and it come out pretty good real good
this is like naan
yeah i mean yeah i remember you doing
that yeah it was
bubbling and everything talking about
this and i was watching like i said i
was watching a couple videos of
people making different kinds of bread
and i was like man this makes me want to
get a bread machine again
so i went on amazon and i was like what
kind of bread machines they got
yeah i think the one i had before i had
one a long time ago my grandmother gave
it to me for christmas one year
and um man i used the [ __ ] out of that
it was so easy
like all you gotta do is throw the
ingredients in there and could be like
yeah i want this kind of bread and
you know this like dark crust medium
crust light crust whatever
then you just turn it on boop and it
just did everything
yeah i'm pretty confident that if i had
some flour some shortening
you know some kind of vegetable
shortening um some water
and maybe a little bit of milk you can
make a pretty decent little dough
and just throw that onto a really hot
rock in the middle of a damn campfire
around the side of a campfire and make a
decent piece of bread
yeah and that's all anybody really wants
that's what they were doing back then
anyway
yeah and i mean there's so much [ __ ] you
can do with yeah
without with really nothing yeah and i
think that's even one of the things that
that guy said it's like that's
what's so awesome about bread it's like
you just take these little like nothing
cheap ingredients
and all of a sudden you can have all
these versatile
yeah delicious if you were some kind of
cowboy on a trail with a horse and
[ __ ] and a mule if you had a cast iron
skillet with a top on it that would help
a lot
yeah you could you could probably you
could make pretty much anything as long
as you had a
cast iron skillet and fire i kind of
feel like everybody should have a cast
iron skillet
yeah if you're cooking at home i mean
yeah because you can make
damn near anything in that [ __ ] yeah
and we
we make all kind of great pizza yeah we
made pizza
we just make everything and that's right
and they're not horribly expensive i
think that one
did i buy you that for christmas money i
think it's a lodge
and uh i think what was it 40 bucks 50
bucks i don't know like that and they
last like forever
yeah did that come with that didn't come
the top on it did it no it didn't no
that one didn't have a topic but you can
buy tops
they're just standard tops standard
sizes
10 inch 12 inch you know yeah but now
that we're talking about it like i said
maybe i'll
maybe maybe i'll buy myself a bread
machine
[Laughter]
what does it do that an oven doesn't do
uh it does everything
besides that like i said it needs it it
needs it
yeah yeah wow like i said you just throw
it it's about this big
huh that's about how big it was like i
said all you have to do is
put all the [ __ ] in there yeah and then
just leave it
and it needs it and then it bakes it in
there too uh-huh wow okay
yeah you didn't know that no i had one
years and years ago
and it it makes like really decent like
it look
it makes like a little decent like
two-pound loaf of bread like that and
like i said you can make any kind of
bread you want in it
yeah you make cinnamon swirl you can
make like you make whatever
you're going to find all different kinds
of uh recipes online
uh different kinds of breads and even
stuff that has oatmeal in it
oh yeah i love oatmeal bread yeah
oatmeal breads
breads with poppy seeds in it sesame
seeds in it
you could put coat it on the outside a
lot of people don't know how that is
that's just another but egg white
just beat up egg white and paint it on
with a damn paintbrush
and then sprinkle it on there before you
bake the bread
and then send it into the oven and it'll
be stuck to the top of it nice glaze
it's pretty nice yeah i mean [ __ ]
like i said somebody said something
about banana bread
which is kind of like the only banana
application that i'll kind of tolerate
there's sweet potato bread there's all
kinds of stuff pumpkin bread
yeah we made a [ __ ] ton of pumpkin bread
when we had all this chocolate
yeah i'd go back we're talking about if
we're gonna throw
pumpkin bread into this mix yeah which
is a quick bread it is type of quick
bread
yeah after thanksgiving
or after halloween go ahead go down and
get those
[ __ ] up um uh
pumpkins all right you haven't you would
not believe how much food is in a
pumpkin
two pumpkins remember remember i said
get some of those big plastic bucket
containers
yeah um
cut up and and roasted i guess
two of those big pumpkins and it filled
up the
two five gallon and that was
literally each each of those pumpkins
and they were big
i think i think they were six dollars
each yeah so it was twelve dollars
for twelve dollars we had more pumpkin
than we could eat and we yeah we got
sick of it
well i didn't really get sick pumpkin
soup pumpkin pies pumpkin bread some of
it i tried to freeze
i did freeze it we made curry curry made
pumpkin curry that [ __ ] was good
wouldn't it yeah with chicken in it yeah
pumpkin curry with chicken yeah we made
all kinds of [ __ ] with that yeah we're
gonna have to do that again this year
yeah it's almost like free food you're
gonna have a jack-o-lantern anyway
yeah and when you put the jack-o-lantern
out don't put it outside put it on a
chair
and put it in a window that's what we
did yeah keep the bugs off of it yeah
because otherwise you're getting yeah
you don't have to use vaseline or
anything on the eyes that's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's indoors it's okay yeah and then
afterwards just
cut slice it up put it on a pan you know
big sheet pan put it in the
oven bake it or roast it and it still
gets soft and then just take a spoon and
it comes out of there creep it
scrape it all off down into a bucket and
then use an
immersion blender and blend it into a
nice uh
sludge and that's slurry
and that slurry right there can be used
to make anything including pancakes
yeah we i don't think we did that but we
were talking about making pancakes with
it or cookies with it we did make a
bunch of bread we made a bunch of pies
uh we made soup man i love pumpkin soup
i have a recipe for that in the uh in
the cookbook actually yeah
yeah people people don't realize how
much food is in one of those pumpkins i
didn't realize
honestly um it tastes like squash
yeah like you can spice it in a bunch of
different ways anything you can do with
squash you can totally do with pumpkin
you can spice it out to be sweet or you
can spice it to be
uh you know what do you call it savory
or put a bunch of indian spices in it
it's good we're off topic though
that's okay we've been going like for 45
minutes yeah it's probably time for the
top talk about bread that's just an
inspiration
for you people that have never made
bread uh it's a good time to
get an understanding on how to make
bread
um it's not intimidating just get over
people are afraid
of getting their hands dirty getting oil
on it and mixing with their hands
you know or they're afraid of messing it
up because like i said it is kind of
finicky but if you mess it up
it doesn't matter it's cheap it didn't
cost anything get you a big old metal
bowl
and some good spatulas or egg flippers
is what i use
and then the vegetable oil big big bags
of flour and yeast and
get to making bread yeah i was scrolling
through the wikipedia page with all the
different kinds of bread because there's
a zillion obviously like from all over
the world and i had remembered
i had totally forgotten about this but
in wales they have a bread called vera
breath
which is kind of like this really dense
bread but it has like um
currants in it and raisins and stuff
it's actually i'm not a big raisin fan
but actually that bread is like really
really good
i haven't had stone bread in a while you
take stone bread you cut the top of it
off you hollow it out put it in a bowl
and then pour
clam chowder in it and then put the top
back on doesn't that sound good
clam chowder inside stone bread and then
you take the pieces of
the pieces of the bread you pulled out
and make something else with it like
croutons
yeah bacon turkey and i haven't had soup
in a bread bowl in a long time
now that's making me want some clam
chowder and a bread yeah
or you could you could bake the internal
stuff and then crumble it up and turn it
into bread crumbs
one thing that i had that i meant to do
when i was in st augustine and i forgot
um in case you didn't know like one one
of the things there's
there's a big thing there for uh one
seafood is a massive thing obviously
because it's right there on the water
uh so there's a ton of like really good
seafood restaurants there with
everything fresh caught
but they're also real well known for one
homemade booze
two homemade chocolate and candy and
three homemade bread
and one of their major things there
which has been there
for a million years like it's it was
there when i was a kid and i'm sure it
was there like
when my parents were kids is the spanish
bakery
and you basically they only make it's a
tiny tiny little place you can't even
eat in there you have to eat like
outside like on the picnic tables or
whatever
they make basically like five things
they make like regular bread they make
like uh
sausage rolls like a you know like a hot
dog inside like a
inside of bread and they make a couple
other things and
basically they get up every day they
make a bunch of bread they put it out
and then you've got to go in there and
buy [ __ ] you sit out on the
uh on the picnic table and eat it and
then once they run out of [ __ ] they
close for the day
tina jumps in and she's asking about
sourdough
asking if it's hard to make usually none
of these breads are hard to make i've
never i never made sourdough
but it's going to be something kind of
like delayed fermentation
where you have it's going to not be hard
but take longer
in other words the dough is going to
have to sit around yeah sourdough
is just the it's the most finicky
because it's the it's the easiest to
mess up yeah
but um you know you just you got to look
at the
tutorial it may have it may have milk in
it
maybe the milk has to be sour when it
goes into the into the dough i'd have to
i'd have to read the recipe
um it's going to have yeast in there too
it might just be
i mean [ __ ] like i said i i haven't made
it
but i can imagine how it's made it's
probably
it probably has sour milk in it too i'm
actually not really sure like i said i'm
not a big sourdough fan
i just know that there was kind of a
mini trend for everybody wanting to make
it and they were always
talking about what a pain in the ass it
was yeah stuff like sourdough evolved
from
accidents it was mistakes uh from the
time before
refrigeration where components
went bad but they were used anyway and
they were like oh man that's good
so who knew yeah that's i think how
cheese
developed rotten milk i mean that's
pretty good
in that direction
then they start to keep pushing it into
a direction trying to make a science out
of how to make something rot and taste
good at the same time
it's not really rotting it's it's a
bacteria culture
it's like extreme yogurt really extreme
but if you smell it
if you have never eaten cheese you would
think that would be a bad idea to eat
that
you'd go oh that can't be good why does
it smell like feet
well especially if it has mold in it
yeah you know like blue cheese and rope
fruit and stuff yeah
it's like hot vomit tastes like vomit
and real spicy
it has that vomit [ __ ] flavor to it
but it's great though
but see that chemical that's in vomit
that makes yeah
that association there's also something
kind of good about it too
yeah it's so powerful that you just have
to accept it you can't fight it you're
like okay
yeah you got me but some of that cheese
is so [ __ ] nasty it's got
living maggots in it and they're eating
it it's super
super expensive some [ __ ] in france but
the french will eat anything
then just rename it they'll just give it
a fancy name oh yeah yeah you can eat
that that's just expensive here you eat
this snail
yeah i mean [ __ ] isn't that good you
know no
i'm not a big fan of snails either or
frogs um
but i can see that's not that weird
because it's like it's just like one
step removed from seafood
and i eat octopus and squid and stuff so
it's like not that weird
yeah it's just i don't know i i don't
know i just
i just not a big fan of like eating
frogs or snails or anything
but uh to answer your question in
general t
um the tutorials and the instructions
for all of that stuff is out there
follow the [ __ ] instructions there's
a reason why they're telling you to do
it that way
and as long as you follow the
instructions it should come out good
most of the time most of the time unless
something unless you're [ __ ] up
or you know shocking flower
that's what i said follow that follow
the directions because
the instructions sometimes have are
specifically telling you to do things
and people will go i don't have to do
that and then they skip that
like no no you have to do that well yeah
there's they're not just saying that for
shits and giggles
i mean there's a reason why right why
it's done but
i would imagine breads like sourdough
and stone bread they probably take a
long time
because the uh um the dough has to cure
or ferment
and probably temperature sensitive maybe
within certain temperatures it can
happen
and they go outside that temperature it
doesn't happen so
you'd have to you'd have to study every
aspect of that recipe get right well i
know for
shouldn't be that hard for making a lot
of breads i think the problem too is
that
especially when it's rising i think
ideally
uh for best results like uh for the
texture and everything
that your kitchen should actually be
kind of warm and humid
yeah so when you have when you live like
in an air-conditioned dry
house sometimes you have to have
work-arounds yeah
or the bread i mean it's not going to
[ __ ] up the bread completely but it's
not going to be like as good as it could
be
you know what i'm saying so it's a you
know it's ambient temperature has a lot
to do with it so like i said bread's a
little bit finicky but some of them are
more finicky than others
grampa's talking about cutting bread out
to get the carbs out of your diet you
lose 15 pounds yeah
yeah true bread is [ __ ] carbohydrate
heavy
yeah you kind of want to keep it to a
minimum if
you if you're afraid of blowing up if
some people
their genes they're just they just get
fat off [ __ ] carbohydrates
really easily you know you give them
anything that's white colored they eat
they blow up
rice potatoes bread you know
pasta yeah blow you up other people can
eat it
seems like uh i've heard that asians can
eat it well in
the united states we call them asians uh
asia's
you know in in england asia means middle
east
talk about like the japanese and the
koreans and the chinese evidently or
their their metabolism allows them to
eat a lot of carbohydrates without
getting fat that's why they're skinny
they say they make a lot of they make a
more insulin
than than uh non-japan yeah because i
mean depending on like what people's
diets have been like throughout the
century thousands of years right yeah
obviously you know if you've
if your people have been in the same
area for a long time and you've been
eating the same diet for a long time
you're gonna like
they've been eating rice for three
thousand years probably two thousand
years
lots of it the whole empire's built on
rice
anybody who could metabolize rice went
extinct
so evidently they got bad ass [ __ ]
bad ass
abilities to get nutrition we ate that
much rice every year
i've weighed 400 pounds yeah
[Laughter]
white people and black people are kind
of omnivorous heavy
meat eating you know and not so much
them you know
like i said they were coming out of
empires built upon rice
yeah right sounds like their main staple
yeah and
even more than i guess wheat was over
here yeah
i feel like yeah no our diets were a lot
more varied i think compared to theirs
yeah they well they ate a lot more uh
seafood and stuff too which is probably
good
well the rich people could when they can
get it yeah you know
but you know over thousands of years
most people were rice peasants they're
in farmers they were poor they just eat
rice just say balls of rice
yeah ball of rice they were lucky to get
some gravy or something
on it that's gotta be real life sucked
most of the time people
we you know we are living in the [ __ ]
best time in human history ever possible
where you can get fruit all year round
no matter where you live
you have citrus fruit no matter where
you live all year round
that was not that was not you know in
the 1800s that was totally impossible
things came into season that was it yeah
that was like a big deal
having a [ __ ] only rich people could
afford oranges and [ __ ] like that if
they were in particular
and certain kind of foods could not be
shipped you just couldn't
transport it it would be [ __ ] up by
the time it got there so
certain foods were only available in the
country of origin
couldn't ship it out too delicate they
smashed too much
[ __ ] like that no way to refrigerate it
uh no way to protect it from [ __ ]
bugs
so our diets they're
the world has never had a diet so varied
now you've still got some places that
are poor and they don't have a whole lot
but in general it's never been this good
when especially when it comes to food
yeah i mean really particularly in the
west you know in the us and europe and
stuff like that it's like you can pretty
much walk out your door and eat whatever
it is
the hell you want to eat i mean without
too much trouble and you can go on you
can go on the internet go on youtube
and see somebody in japan cooking a dish
and you can go okay i'm gonna make that
and you can make it you can get all the
components and everything
that was unheard of you couldn't do that
in the 80s
yeah i was gonna say you couldn't do
that when i was a kid nope and that
wasn't that long ago you just had to
wonder
you had to wonder yeah how they did that
and then you had to buy a cookbook and
and you hoped that that it was accurate
that the information was accurate you
know it's just funny to think about now
because everything's so much easier
and everything is accelerating really
quickly like like just say for instance
guys that are into like guns and
reloading ammunition and high-tech [ __ ]
they're on youtube showing each other
and talking to each other and
designing things together and
technology is accelerating faster
because everybody can see what everybody
else is doing
that was not a possible you could do
that even in the 90s
well yeah that's what i'm saying that's
why everything's well just because it's
you can instantly find out what other
people are doing or doing right
other side of the world like right now
you got guys scattered out
40 50 dudes scattered out across the
globe all working on the same problem at
the same time
talking to each other and showing video
evidence and high-speed
film of bullets passing through
ballistic gelatin and [ __ ]
high-speed film man when i was a kid
that was a million a high-speed camera
was a million dollars
these dudes are just doing it with
something like a damn cell phone yep
slow motion picture of a [ __ ] time
will be alive yeah
only a government agency had the ability
to get a picture of a bullet slowly
moving through things
[ __ ] amazing man i remember seeing
documentaries like that when i was a kid
of like all the slow motion photography
it was like yeah now it's comment place
everybody has it oh yeah now everybody's
got that [ __ ]
yeah yeah grantham's hammer is talking
about uh
native americans not having the uh
enzymes for
alcohol hence why they can't drink
alcohol or why it like affects them
worse than it does
yeah europeans it was the same at
pacific islanders man when we were in
the army those dudes would go berserk
right give them a drink and they shove
their head through the wall
start fighting each other my friend
gordon cut off [ __ ] speech [ __ ]
thumb
did a fight with a knife remember him
that i told you about him yeah
he became an army ranger later on
afterwards he went to the stockade when
he came out
they did sew the thumb back on right
yeah they put it back on
it went mostly through the bone the bone
was cracking and
over oh man maybe i was like oh
think about it oh i don't want to think
about it
i know like the rest of the
oh i remembered what that [ __ ] looked
like oh
i know i can imagine yeah yeah yeah
what's funny is like
somebody tossed me a girl's head in a
ziploc bag and that didn't bother me but
seeing [ __ ] speech thumb and we went
like that it went
it was like oh god i did it again man
ooh
yeah don't do that that's like watching
people's like fingernails
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like yeah like
be heading and said that's awful but
it's like for some reason like little
[ __ ] like that like your fingers yeah
you're spending the whole time
like that it's just like really yeah you
couldn't kill a stream or like i said
you know
sometimes when i'm walking through the
kitchen and like the floor is slippery
yeah and like i'll kind of slide or
something i'm like oh man what would
happen if like i slipped and like fell
right on my face and then like my teeth
went through my lip and all this other
kind of [ __ ] wow that'd be awful
but uh yeah so like i said talking about
bread has made me want to buy a bread
machine maybe i'll go buy a bread
machine after the show's over
because i used to have one and i used to
really like it i used it all the time
because it's you know it's it's fresh
bread but it's
like not any work really which is kind
of nice you don't have to need it you
don't have to
you just kind of pop it all in there and
then like a few hours later ta-da it's
all done
but yeah all right so we will be back uh
tomorrow i can't believe we were going
on for an hour
yeah an hour show yeah uh so we'll be
back tomorrow as usual we're probably
gonna do a movie might
do one of these ones that uh no need for
me to send us because he sent us a big
pile
of movies along with the laptop so maybe
we'll watch one of those tonight and
review that tomorrow so that'll be fun
all right
so hopefully you guys enjoyed the show
have a good rest of your weekend
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
bye